new in theaters this weekend countdown
and black and blue well you see this is
your weekend ticket whatever is
happening to us I think it's because
this CDs in your phone and you phone
your number your service anything else I
can help you with no
[Music]
[Applause]
the horror movie countdown comes out
this weekend when Quinn downloads the
new trendy app named countdown that
tells you how long you have before you
die it reveals she has just short of
three days now she's in a panic race to
find out if the app is fake or if she
has only days to live this movies for
you if a suspense horror film sounds
good this weekend you're a fan of
Twilight Zone or black mirror type
premises or you're ready to have a fun
weekend in 10987 you get I got I mean to
see all this you already got rid of
everyone that could talk
the hell are you doing here bookie relax
no cups here this is what it looks get a
body cam on but we gotta go
she's gone black and blue comes out this
weekend when a rookie cop catches the
shady deal that ends in murder on her
police body cam she's shot but escapes
and is now on the run from the people
who tried to kill her both criminals and
crooked cops this movies for you if
you're looking for an intense action
this weekend you're a fan of movies like
training day or you didn't know this
whole show is recorded on a head cam
isn't that right camera woman that is
your weekend ticket what will you see
and check back next week if you'll be
back red and a terminator impression oh
it's supposed to say it you'll be back